on en vient à l'actualité sociale en
france à présent avec le conseil d'état
qui a validé la réforme de l'assurance
chômage hier et donc elle a validé le
principe d'un nouveau calcul de
l'allocation pour plus d'explications va
justement retrouver notre reporter lima
rosie devant le conseil d'état ce matin
[Musique]
bonjour guillemin vous êtes donc devant
le conseil d'état qui a clôt donc un
dossier ouvert il ya deux ans et demi
maintenant
et oui c'est ça ma galice cette réforme
de l'assurance chômage c'est edouard
philippe qu'il avait présenté le 18 juin
dernier il y a trente mois à 30 mois
d'un parcours mouvementé le texte a été
retouchée amendé reporter suspendu y
compris par le conseil d'état lui même
qui en juin dernier avait considéré que
la situation économique en france
n'était pas compatible avec
l'application de cette réforme sauf que
depuis le contexte a changé et hier les
juges de la plus haute juridiction
administrative ont rejeté un à un les
arguments des différents syndicats fin
de partie donc pour la bataille
juridique il reste encore une audience
sur le fond purement formelle mais
l'essentiel de cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage a donc bel et bien
été définitivement adopté mais validé
magali et concrètement guillemin
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui va changer
alors rien de moins que le plus
important c'est à dire le mode de calcul
du sjr c'est à dire le salaire
journalier de référence il est désormais
calculée sur la base des salaires perçus
au cours des dames des derniers 24 mois
sur l'ensemble des jours et non plus sur
les seuls jours travaillés ce qui va
faire mathématiquement baisser les
allocations de ceux qui n'auraient pas
travailler de façon continue sur cette
période la réforme prévoit aussi et
qu'il faut désormais avoir travaillé au
minimum six mois au lieu de quatre
auparavant pour pouvoir être indemnisés
est alors en pratique il manquait ce que
ça va changer pour les demandeurs
d'emploi cette fois
alors en gros pour ceux qui auraient
travaillé en cdi au cours des deux
dernières années pas grand chose pour
les autres eh ben c'est une toute autre
affaire surtout pour les plus fragiles
pour les plus précaires pour les permis
tant c'est à dire ceux qui ont coutume
d'alterner les contrats cours et les
périodes de chômage l'unedic prévoit à
15,15 millions d'allocataires devraient
voir leur indemnisation baissé d'environ
17% et ce sera beaucoup plus pour
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'entre
eux avec parfois des reports des
ouvertures de droits reporter la réforme
de l'assurance chômage devraient
permettre d'économiser environ plus de 2
milliards d'euros par an c'est deux fois
plus que ce sur quoi table et l'exécutif
ouais merci beaucoup guy marosi en
direct du conseil d'état sma